c'est l'actif le plus précieux des
agriculteurs pourtant on l'a longtemps
ignoré et encore aujourd'hui on le
connaît mal je vous parle évidemment du
sol qui nous rend d'innombrables
services comme de nourrir des milliards
d'êtres humains sur la terre chaque jour
pourtant les sols ne se porte pas bien
il est grand temps qu'on prenne soin
d'eux voici notre grand dossier sur la
santé des sols
[Musique]
nous sommes au début mais jim bryson a
quelque chose à nous montrer
sous ces petites sert bien à l'abri
pouces ce qu'il appelle ses bébés
sous chaque ministère se cache un plan
de citrouilles que jim va bichonner
pendant des mois car c'est un amateur de
concours de citrouilles géantes
un jour mon cousin m'a offert un blanc
qui a produit une citrouille de près de
300 kg
chaque année depuis jeudi que je vais
arrêter mais quand le printemps arrive
c'est plus fort que moi
agriculteur retraité il a travaillé
toute sa vie de manière conventionnelle
il laboure est la terre et utiliser des
engrais chimiques et des pesticides et
c'est d'abord de cette manière qu'il
fait pousser ses citrouilles
2011 j'ai établi le record du monde avec
une citrouille de 850 kg et je
comprenais rien au sol et c'était de la
chance plus qu'autre chose
il a toutefois l'impression de plafonner
son sol s'épuise et pour grossir ses
citrouilles ont besoin de toujours plus
d'engrais c'est alors qu'un déclic se
produit
je suis mis à faire des cultures de
couverture et ça a amélioré mon sol de
manière incroyable tous les
micro-organismes qui lie à dans le sol
des plantes russe
des cultures de couverture comme ce
segment bien vivant dans lequel jim à
implanter ses citrouilles cette année à
toute petite échelle jim nourrit donc
son sol avec du fumier et des plantes
ça peut paraître banal mais c'est une
petite révolution
le sol est essentiel à notre survie
95 % de nos aliments proviennent d'une
mince couche de sol à la surface de la
terre
depuis dix mille ans on le cultive et
nous nourrit mais dans les cent
dernières années l'agriculture s'est
intensifié à vitesse grand v
aujourd'hui les sols sont à bout de
souffle
l'organisation des nations unies pour
l'alimentation et l'agriculture la fao
considère que le tiers des terres
agricoles de la planète est déjà
dégradée alors qu'il faut milan pour
régénérer 2 à 3 cm de terre arable
[Musique]
l'agriculture subi des transformations
très importante surtout en matière de
mécanisation bien sûr petit à petit on
en est arrivé à un système qui est
beaucoup plus artificielle qui est
artificialisé en fait par rapport à ce
qu'on veut trouver dans la nature
alain ollivier est un spécialiste
d'agroécologie on est parti de systèmes
paysans où il y avait une diversité à la
fois de plantes et même d'animaux on
avait une intégration étroite de
l'agriculture et de l'élevage à des
systèmes très spécialisés où on a une
unique culture sur des dizaines ou même
des centaines d'hectares à la fois au
fil des ans les monocultures ont
accéléré la perte de fertilité des sols
les monocultures ça marche ça marche et
évidemment pendant un certain temps ç'a
permis d'avoir un rendement élevé d'une
seule culture ça simplifie beaucoup les
choses en matière de récolte par exemple
très vite on s'est rendu compte que on
avait des problèmes de dégradation des
sols par exemple parce qu'on a des
cultures qui exploite toujours la même
couche de sol qui ont le même type
d'investissement
au cours du siècle dernier de nouveaux
produits ont permis au rendement de
faire des bonds de géant les engrais
chimiques des produits adopté à grande
échelle sans qu'on en mesure toujours
les impacts sur le sol on sait peu de
choses de ce qui se passe dans le sol
puis malheureusement bon de jouer un peu
aux apprentis sorciers je dirais
on s'est dit avec les avancées de la
chimie par exemple il suffit d'ajouter
un peu d'azoté un peu de phosphore un
peu de potassium on brasse tout ça on
fait des quantités qu'il faut et puis on
va avoir un bon rendement de la plante
c'est vrai à court terme mais ce dont on
s'est pas rendu compte en fait c'est que
le sol c'est beaucoup plus qu'une
addition d'éléments chimiques c'est un
milieu qui est grouillant de vie c'est
un milieu vivant
pour comprendre de quoi il s'agit ça
vaut la peine de faire un trou et les
regarder de plus près
car olivier gauche et conseille des
agriculteurs en s'inspirant des
principes de l'agroécologie une approche
qui mise entre autres sur l'incroyable
pouvoir des plantes
ici la première vue ça bouge pas on
dirait que rien qui se passe et pourtant
si on regarde avec un microscope
quelques on verrait dans une cuillère à
soupe qui représente 15 g de sol on peut
avoir entre 6 et 9 milliards
d'organismes vivants il y a donc plus
d'organismes vivants dans une cuillère
et de sol qui lie à d'êtres humains sur
la terre ce qui fait du sol l'un des
plus grands réservoirs de biodiversité
de la planète des insectes bénéfiques il
ya des micro-organismes bénéfique un
paquet de bactéries de champignons
certaines de ces petites créatures vont
décomposer la matière organique d'autres
sont capables d'extraire les minéraux de
la roche et de les rendre disponibles
pour les plantes d'autres encore protège
les végétaux des pathogènes et ce ne
sont que quelques exemples de ce qui se
passe sous nos pieds plus on produit
biomasse aérienne et souterraine plus la
biodiversité augmente dans ce hall plus
la biodisponibilité désigne les éléments
nutritifs va augmenter aussi plus et
biodisponible plus on produit de belles
récoltes de belles couvertures
tout est relié tout est lié les
scientifiques considèrent qu'on ne
connaît qu'une infime partie de tous les
micro organismes du sol mais on sait que
leur équilibre est affecté entre autres
par les engrais et les pesticides le
problème des fongicides et insecticides
c'est qu'ils sont rarement très sélectif
c'est à dire qu'ils vont affecter will
insectes dont on voudrait se débarrasser
affecté le champignon dont on voudrait
se débarrasser mais bon en affecter
aussi plein d'autres organismes qui sont
des organismes utiles
chaque année au canada près 200 millions
de kilogrammes de pesticides sont
utilisés dans les champs cultivés des
produits qui améliorent les rendements à
court terme mais qui se retrouve un peu
partout dans l'environnement et
contaminent notamment les cours d'eau
pourtant il y aurait d'autres façons de
faire
nous sommes à la fin avril les feuilles
commencent à peine à sortir
tous bruns les champs émergent de
l'hiver mais certaines parcelles déjà
verte se démarque ici le seigle forme un
beau tapis
avec les sags y parle pas c'est vrai au
printemps il s'est promis qu'ils
comprennent
andré charbonneau et producteur laitier
à saint-marc-sur-richelieu depuis une
dizaine d'années il couvre ses champs en
permanence et il ne laboure plus
tôt que les plantes font travail
mécanique en face à vannes en place des
recettes faut qu'il y ait plus de vie
dans ce hall en place que les mécaniques
ses meilleurs selon moi
on est un peu de vie dans seul tout
l'enfant répond au mieux
selon lui il faut changer notre façon de
voir le sol et faire confiance à sa
fertilité naturelle son travail et sa
bombe aux engrais chimiques ces derniers
comme un sport les plans mais son sens
maintenant à gré pour eux savaient quel
que ce soit nous donne
toute la sphère rapporte que la batteur
d'abord un an
après sa récolte de céréales au mois
d'août l'agriculteur a tout de suite
ressemer des cultures de couverture
arriver à l'automne le mélange multi
espèces et luxuriant car ça ces plantes
andré charbonneau a pu réduire de moitié
les engrais chimiques sur sa ferme dans
ses champs de maïs on voit aussi comment
les cultures de couverture entre les
rangs barre la voie aux mauvaises herbes
en occupant l'espace ce qui diminue
l'utilisation des pesticides
pour approfondir la question retrouvons
pierre-olivier gauche et sur sa terre à
contrecoeur
[Musique]
elle bien rallier
selon lui il faut de toute urgence
cesser de se battre contre la nature et
essayez plutôt de limiter
un seul couvrance un sol fertile il est
le printemps c'est quoi qu'il va les
gazons les prairies les fossés les bars
de fausser le chanu ne pousse pas ça va
prendre un mois un mois et demi ce temps
photosynthèse lassé de l'énergie pour
qui pour nous et nos employés dans notre
usine qui ne sonne trisa soir la
rhizosphère c'est la zone qui entoure
les racines c'est un lieu d échanges
intenses entre les plantes et les
champignons mycorhiziens notamment les
mycorhizes c'est quoi ces des
champignons qui s'associe aux racines
donc ils cognent à la porte de la
rationalité écoute moi j'veux pas
capables de produire de la photosynthèse
donc d'avoir déçu que je changerais des
sucs compte du territoire je vais à
l'expérience du territoire pour toi je
suis visé des éléments nutritifs que
t'es pas capable de se mobiliser qui on
va vivre en symbiose pour on va bien
s'entendre cette alliance va permettre
aux plantes d'avoir accès à des éléments
essentiels à leur croissance et leur
santé comme le magnésium le calcium
lezin sous ces éléments vont développer
un système umi tas de planches beaucoup
plus élevé qui va être beaucoup moins
favorisés par la tacc de ravageurs de
champignons de maladies fongiques tout
ça c'est une synergie 3 les arbres à
côté de nous ils sont pratiquement
jamais malade parce qu'une synergie un
écosystème il faut créer l'écosystème
cultiver
pour que ça fonctionne il faut donc
perturber ce milieu là le moins possible
depuis l'antiquité on laboure pour
ameublir le sol et préparer les semis
pendant des siècles on l'a fait avec des
animaux et des outils rudimentaires
aujourd'hui on laboure pour les mêmes
raisons mais la machinerie est beaucoup
plus lourde est autrement plus puissante
ce qui a des conséquences sur tout ce
qui vit dans le sol les galeries des
insectes et des animaux bénéfiques comme
les vers de terre sont détruites des
réseaux de champignons mycorhiziens
déchiré
dès qu'on travaille au sol on brise ses
chaînes de mycorhizes là ils vont se
reformer parce que la nature est
extrêmement résilient mais à mesure
qu'on un sol qui s'appauvrit qui devient
marrant guide mais on ne paquet de
carence qui apparaissent dans les
végétaux
pourquoi la grille du conventionnel ici
c'est les engrais de synthèse et les
pesticides c'est parce que le seul et
peut vivre si les pratiques modernes ont
contribué à nuire aux écosystèmes on
peut désormais penser l'agriculture
autrement et des solutions existent pour
redonner vie aux sols dégradés ce qui
est merveilleux c'est que on peut faire
des écosystèmes cultiver plus que de
faire des des monocultures avec des
chants à nu entre les reins pourquoi ça
fonctionne quand conflit seul parce
qu'on imite la nature
c'est pas juste une question d'écologie
c'est une question de production aussi
aujourd'hui et demain dans notre projet
futur
après la pause comme anges erick les
plantes de couverture
[Musique]
couvrir le sol ça apporte toutes sortes
davantage ça permet de lutter contre
l'érosion d'améliorer la fertilité la
structure du sol les apus faire en bio
comment conventionnel un grande comme à
toute petite échelle
[Musique]
nous retrouvons jim bryson au mois de
juin depuis notre dernière visite les
plantes citrouilles ont pris de
l'ampleur
cette vigne va pousser de 20-25 cm par
jour
les fleurs seront bientôt polliniser
s'il veut espérer battre le record de la
plus grosse citrouille jim bryson doit
traiter son sol aux petits oignons et
pour éviter de l'épuiser il fait des
rotations
voici l'une des parcelles qui
accueillera les citrouilles de 2022
l'automne dernier jim a planté ici du
seigle et de la vsv lui ces plantes ont
survécu à l'hiver et sont repartis de
plus belle au printemps
en s'associant avec les bactéries du sol
la baisse comme tout les légumineuses
arrive à capter l'azoté de l'air cet
azote sera ensuite disponible pour
fertiliser les citrouilles le seigle qui
produit une masse racinaire
impressionnante contribue quant à lui à
améliorer la structure du sol
et comme il faut de la variété même
quand on nourrit des micro organismes et
les vers de terre jim saupoudre ces
plantes de feuilles mortes
et la saison ensuite le tout d'un
mélange de 12 g différentes et puis il
brasse
[Musique]
il faudra quand même un pote alors tout
couper je sème les graines de la
prochaine crise tueur
dans dix jours elles auront germé
il ya toujours quelque chose qui pousse
c'est comme dans la nature on ne voit
jamais une terre où il ne pousse rien
[Musique]
toujours des plantes de la clé pour
bâtir le seul
pendant l'été jim coup prend ainsi trois
fois sont couverts pour maximiser la
fertilité de sa terre et à sa grande
surprise sans aucun labour les petites
graines déposé à la surface finissent
toujours par germer malgré l'épaisse
couche de 2,6 g de feuilles ça fait cinq
ans que je fais ça et à chaque fois je
me dis que ça ne marche comme moi mais
ça fonctionne toujours je n'ai pas
labourer depuis jeunes charrues flambant
neuf mais je pense que je ne
l'utiliserai jamais
cette façon de faire a complètement
changé l'alluré du sol la fille de jim
quel psy qui partage aussi sa passion
pour les citrouilles géantes s'étonne de
la différence
quand j'étais jeune pékin ont tourné le
sol tu peux voir la terre était pas
fertile comme l'est aujourd'hui il y
avait
et moins de vrd tard il y avait moins de
biodiversité dans les salles
cet été
auparavant on croyait que la terre
idéale était formé de grains fins comme
tu sais maintenant on sait qu'une terre
en santé et pleine de rigueur
le mot à retenir ici c'est biodiversité
[Musique]
chacune de ces petites semences
deviendra une plante de couverture qui
nourrira le sol à sa façon
plus on va mettre des racines plus on va
structurer le sol plus on empile les
couches de carbone qui devient de
l'humus plus on est résilient la
sécheresse et lorsque la plante et ses
racines vont se décomposer une foule
d'éléments nutritifs seront alors
disponibles dans le sol quand jean
magazine dans un tissu d'une plante
exemples comme ceux sarrazin le
j'emmagasine des éléments nutritifs
dedans ils peuvent pas partir aux ovins
comme le phosphore par dans les cours
d'eau ou par paréo érosion éolienne ils
peuvent pas partir au vent ils peuvent
pas se perdre ils sont transforme en
humus cette mesure va se minéraliser le
moment venu couvrir les sols en
permanence permet donc d'éviter ceux ci
le mois de mai c'est le mois des semis
mais c'est aussi celui des panaches de
poussière quand on sème dans un sol à nu
c'est le spectacle qui s'offre à nous ce
que le vent transporte ici c'est de la
précieuse terres arables et ce sont
aussi des résidus d'engrais et de
pesticides
et voyez ce qui arrive quand on sème
dans du vivant pas une seule particules
de sol ne s'envolent ici un champ de
seigle reçoit un semis de soya plus
lourd ce soir a été adapté pour pouvoir
planter les graines directement à
travers la couverture vivante mais ce
qui sera vendu au final c'est le soya il
faut alors éviter que le seigle ne
vienne lui faire de l'ombre et pompé
tout son nous
maintenant que cette culture de
couverture a rempli sa mission de
nourrir le sol il est temps de la
détruire
on sort donc le glyphosate pour se
débarrasser du couvert et laisser la
voie libre à la culture principale
agro écologie ne signifie pas
agriculture biologique les pesticides ne
sont donc pas strictement interdite
l'agroécologie son maillon faible c'est
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires donc les herbicides plus
particulièrement pour débarrasser le
couvert comme ça ça prend du glyphosate
on a développé des techniques où on
utilise un peu moins de glyphosate mais
on en utilise encore
l'agroécologie insiste beaucoup sur la
transition vers des systèmes agricoles
ou des systèmes alimentaires durables
donc dans cette perspective là utilisé
du pli fô that ce n'est pas gros
écologique mais on peut comprendre qu'un
agriculteur dans une transition vers une
agriculture durable va peut-être
l'utiliser pendant un certain temps mais
avec l'objectif quand même de pouvoir
s'en passer à plus ou moins brève
échéance alors que faire si on veut
réduire l'utilisation des herbicides et
qu'on ne veut pas non plus nuire aux
fragiles équilibres qui règne dans le
sol une partie de la solution se trouve
peut-être dans l'histoire qui suit
nous sommes à princeville à la ferme de
michel thibodeau
qui est beau c'est une super protection
contre le gel
meilleure protection aujourd'hui deux
agronomes qui suivent les champs de ce
producteur ont fait le déplacement
car michel thibodeau se livre à une
expérience plutôt inusité
en ce 10 juin le seigle atteint les
épaules et malgré les apparences ceci
est un championnat comme la ferme de
grandes cultures est en régie biologique
impossible pour michel thibodeau
d'utiliser des herbicides pour se
débarrasser des mauvaises herbes il
aurait pu faire comme ses confrères
producteurs bio et cercle entre l'iran
moi j'aimais passe à sarcler donne donc
quand tu aimes pas quelque chose devient
jamais bon donc j'évite me laissa clair
dans l'entrepôt puis passer à autre
chose il a donc adopté la technique du
soya dans du seigle rouler le segway est
aplati à 3,4 endroit là il va être là
dessus je veux être brisée à peu près à
toutes les sauces là puis une fois qui
est bien bien à placer au sol de bain
ils vont mourir le il va sécher puis le
veau faire un pays de deux parutions
peut dire l'odeur feuilles de seigle
l'idée de rouler une culture n'est pas
nouvelle depuis des décennies des
producteurs bio aux états unis se
servent de rouleaux pour détruire
entièrement des cultures de couverture
aux états unis union plus long de 16 ans
où ils pouvaient rouler le seigle la
presse au sommet un seuil haut à en
étant assez certain de le rendre matin
maturité là
pour éviter que le seigle ne repousse
après avoir été roulé il faut attendre
sa pleine floraison ce qui arrive vers
la mi juin à cette date il est déjà très
tard au québec pour semer du soya et
espérer avoir une bonne récolte
chez michel thibodeau le rouleau conçu
par l'agriculteur est fabriqué sur
mesure permet donc d'éviter le soya
semer un mois plus tôt entre les rangs
de seigle
la particularité c'est que tout se
déroule au devin impose donc il reste un
espace pour le seigneur qui est pas
rouler ici à l'automne dernier ce que
c'était un radis moutarde
ou
la technique a débuté l'automne
précédent l'agriculteur a semé de rang
deux siècles qui ont survécu à l'hiver
et deux rangs d'une culture de
couverture ici c'était de la moutarde et
du radi qui eux sont morts à la saison
froide
c'est dans cet espace libre qu'il a
implanté son seuil à début mai le but de
mettre 2,5 c'est vraiment de faire un
pays qui va empêcher le plus possible la
croissance des mauvaises heures
l'agronome julian wilkinson mène un
projet de recherche pour mesurer
l'impact de cette approche novatrice ce
que ça fait le sexe c'est qu'il ya un
petit peu moins de lumière qui va
pénétrer dans le couvert végétal donc le
soya il va chercher la lumière qu'on
remarque sur les plans c'est que la tige
est peut-être un petit peu étiolé le par
rapport à un seuil haut qui serait semé
pendant un couvert végétal
michel thibodeau pour fine cette
technique depuis 2018 le rendement de
son soya est équivalent au soya sarcler
dans sa région le producteur sauve aussi
plusieurs passages de machinerie et donc
de l'argent selon ses calculs les
économies atteignent en moyenne 250 $
l'hectare sans compter les avantages
pour la vie du sol
tafnout à flot tout ce que dans le sol
change jetant avec un métabolisme de sol
qui est beaucoup plus rapide puis qui
est capable de prendre du carbone bleu
transformé prendre de matière sèche la
transformer en humain stable et il est
convaincu qu'il y encore beaucoup de
place à l'amélioration
la technique conventionnelle avec du
roundup ready là ça fait
30 ans qu'on fait cela avec du roundup
ready il ya des producteurs qu'il
améliore encore le même
ex si on avait mis autant d'efforts pour
mettre au point des techniques comme ça
puis se faisait trente ans qu'on les
pratiquer
on se serait probablement bien
d'ailleurs qu'on est lourd logent les
fêtes avec du ceg mais un jour des
producteurs vont l'essayer avec d'autres
types de plantes puis peut-être les
résultats on est encore meilleur
revendez on va arriver avec des choix de
plantes puis d ingénierie de machines
qui vont faire en sorte qu'on on veut
vraiment bien maîtrisé la technique avec
un impact à long terme un impact sur le
sol qui sera meilleur
[Musique]
depuis le début de cette émission on
vous parle de l'importance des racines
pour la santé des sols mais de quoi
ont-elles l'air au juste
[Musique]
voici comment s'expriment certaines
plantes sous la terre
dans une obscurité sans fleurs ni
couleur règne pourtant une grande beauté
[Musique]
ses dessins on en compte plus de 1000
sont le travail titanesque d'une
botaniste autrichienne lors kucera
pendant plus de 40 ans avec sa petite
équipe elle a déterré minutieusement des
plantes dans une folle d'environnement
pour en dessiner ensuite le profil
racinaire souvent la partie aérienne les
tiges les feuilles ne représente même
pas 50% de toute la biomasse de la
plante cette collection à la frontière
de l'art et de la science a été
entièrement numérisée et donne à voir
l'étonnante face cachée des plantes
après la pause des animaux pour
améliorer la santé des sols
[Musique]
mi septembre chez jim mickle si bryson
c'est le sprint final dans la course à
la plus grosse citrouille
il pulvérise débit aux stimulants à base
de plantes sur les feuilles
[Musique]
bien dissimulée sous de multiples
couverture un énorme fruits oranges
trône désormais au milieu du jardin
[Musique]
la culture des citrouilles est
extrêmement gourmandes en eau mais les
bryson remarque que depuis qu'il
s'inspire de l'agroécologie beaucoup de
choses ont changé
le seul n'est plus le même il ya toute
une vie de da
devant un rosé beaucoup moins maintenant
on utilisait sans gallons d'eau car
plate par journée maintenant on utilise
50 gallons par semaine pour trois
plantes alors on utilise vraiment moins
de l'oph on utilisait à voir mais est ce
que tous ces changements seront
suffisants pour obtenir une citrouille
gagnante cette année entre père et fille
les avis sont partagés
les citerai qu'on amène à on veut qu'il
soit au moins de mai lui offrir
son vol
[Musique]
avance d'un coup sûr depuis le début de
l'émission on a évoqué l'agroécologie
une approche d'agriculture durable qui
mise entre autres sur la santé de tout
l'écosystème
récemment on entend aussi parler
d'agriculture
régénératrice les deux termes ne sont
pas tout à fait synonyme mais certains
piliers reviennent souvent comme
l'intégration des plantes pérennes et
des animaux
à tous les jours je vais supporter mes
vaches au pâturage puis je regarde le
sol bien me donne de quoi tu les joues
lui là que je me dis quoi faut n'en
pense rien
juste à la vigne et producteurs laitiers
dans l'est de l'ontario en ce beau jour
de mai ses 45 vaches se régale de fois
nouveau et une salade de pissenlits
frais
ils vont manger le ceg 100 lits en
premier regardez
si la santé du sol passe par des racines
vivante celle qu'on trouve sur sa ferme
ne peuvent pas se plaindre d'être
dérangé trop souvent la taille laissez
moi j'ai pas souvent on se rappelle
quand j'étais petit on enterrait déchets
depuis le tir
ça tarde de 160 hectares est entièrement
en foin un mélange de plantes pérennes
comme le trèfle et le lotier qui peuvent
survivre pendant des années de la
portance mais si tu vois le sait bien
établie de la grosse racine même sam lpi
l'étude même si ils mouillent leur
chante à blanc d'où a qu'à leurs
homologues la différence d'enracinement
des plantes vivaces par rapport aux
annuel est impressionnante sur cette
image on peut voir la profondeur qui
atteignent les racines du blé une plante
annuelle par rapport à celle du carna
une vivace
[Musique]
un tel ancrage dans le sol permet entre
autres aux plans de puiser l'eau plus
loin dans la terre
pour avoir assez de nourriture pour ses
vaches justin lavigne sème aussi
plusieurs plans différentes danses et
chants
malgré la sécheresse des derniers étés
il n'a jamais manqué de foin on connaît
à peu toutes les particularités du sol
il ya des plantes qui s'adaptent mieux
d'autres - va maintenant plusieurs
espèces ça me donne l'oeil aussi de voir
qu'est ce qui pousse le mieux mais même
ça pose bien je continue à mettre des
autres plantes je reprends en faire une
monoculture jeu c'est une culture si
elle a tout juste plus rien
[Musique]
ces vaches qui foulent les champs imite
ce que l'on pouvait voir sur une bonne
partie de l'amérique du nord il y à
quelques centaines d'années d'intel et
byzance formé à grandeur du canada puis
il y avait des prairies partout le
laboureur pour les maisons le show et
puis il
est cette année justin lavigne s'est
inspiré encore plus du passage de ces
grands ruminants contrairement à son
habitude il n'a même pas faucher ces
prairies stetrice était très s'est vu
quand j'ai laissé la plaine langage pour
au tirage en plus piétine j'ai gardé mon
industrie c'est ce qui donne un petit
look hirsute aux pâturages avec des
touffes de plantes plus mature que les
vaches ont laissé au chant souvent dans
ces plantes leur batterie todt las manos
naturel qui s'est fait tacler leur
piétine il le renvoie à terre fait
techniquement la semence maé est la
touche la terre si un peu du ministre
iba à voir prendre
d'autres plantes donc mais hbo sera
chaude où la densité et d'armes des
pistes à sec
pour maximiser la vie du sol juste est
adopté la technique du pâturage rotatif
ces chants qui sont divisé en petites
parcelles par des clôtures électriques
amovible à chaque 12 heures ils les
déplacent les vaches reviendront brouter
la même parcelle vingt jours plus tard
pendant cette pause la planta le temps
de repousser et de faire croître son
système racinaire
aucun engrais chimique n'est utilisé les
vaches fertilise elles mêmes leurs
prairies sans tracteur ni pétrole
réjean nutriments la bourse servira de
nourriture aux insectes et aux
microorganismes du sol à cela s'ajoutent
les restes de plantes qui vont se
décomposer
qu'est ce qui suit vous dans ce secteur
des résidus comme ça pour passer l'hiver
moi je dis ça ça nourrit mon sol les
oublie la vie microbienne des lots de
quoi se nourrir
cet équilibre entre le sol les plantes
et les animaux se répercute dans les
rendements la ferme de justin la vigne
produit du lait de vaches nourries à
l'herbe relais de niche pour lequel il
obtient une prime et fourrages de
meilleure qualité permettent à ses
vaches de produire 1 est plus gras nous
on est pays aussi pour les coureurs que
dans notre les fêtes plus augmentent est
mieux que c'est pour moi le gros en
augmentèrent j'ai besoin de moins de
vaches donc le j'en ai moins à nourrir
parce que je remplis le même volume et
au delà des avantages pour les fermes
prises individuellement agir pour
favoriser la santé du sol bénéficie à
toute la société on va profiter par
exemple de une meilleure qualité de
l'eau ce qui veut dire qu'on aura moins
à dépenser pour le traitement de l'eau
potable
l'agriculture c'est pas seulement
produire des aliments c'est aussi
protéger un écosystème protéger la
biodiversité d'ensemble protéger la
qualité de l'eau protéger la santé
humaine aussi
au cours de ce reportage tous les
producteurs interviews et nous ont fait
part d'emblée de leur préoccupation
quant à la qualité de l'environnement
à saint-marc-sur-richelieu andré
charbonneau s'inquiète de la rivière où
ils se baignaient quand il était jeune
aujourd'hui la métropole ouvre ses
portes à angelina juste la couleur mais
n'est pas pour te détruire de l'autre
pour est revenu sur vivable
couvrir les sols et sa façon de réduire
la pollution tous les impacts
environnementaux sont jamais calculé on
n'assume jamais la partie
environnementale de la pollution on
l'appelle en avant tout le temps en aval
aux générations
j'ai des enfers building chose que moi
j'ai fait pas étrangère aux jeux pour
l'épaule eurent transmettre qu'est ce
que j'ai fait avec mes grands parents
puis mon père
je saleh apparaît à l'arrière et une
rivière tagab de vendre des poissons
voulez vous voyez c'est pas au centre de
nos jambes c'est je peux pas transmettre
ça mais en fait
c'est parce c'est sûr mais je veux pas
l'empiré
après la pause des géants de
l'agroalimentaire s'intéresse à la santé
des sols
[Musique]
prendre soin du sol de tout l'écosystème
ce n'est pas limitée aux petites fermes
aux petites superficies de grandes
compagnies s'y intéressent aussi pepsi
cola car guilde généraux mise ces
multinationales ont chacun annoncé des
objectifs en agriculture est génératrice
totalisant des millions d'hectares
les prairies canadiennes
le grenier du pays et d'une partie du
monde
la sécheresse historique de l'été
dernier a fait mal ici les rendements
ont reculé de 30 à 40% et on s'attend à
ce que ces événements extrêmes
augmentent en fréquence
si l'on veut produire pour la population
mondiale de demain il faudra que les
terres puissent mieux s'adapter à ces
nouvelles conditions
celle et la hollande on est agriculteur
depuis des générations
riani et son père viennent d'afrique du
sud en 2010 est la famille achète une
ferme de bovins et de grandes cultures
dans la région de yorkton saskatchewan
la terre n'est pas en bon état épuisé
par des années de monoculture même les
pâturages sont mal en point après la
première année on s'est rendu compte
qu'on avait dépensé beaucoup pour de
l'engrais des pesticides et on arrivait
à peine à faire nos frais en travaillant
toute l'année
alors on s'est dit il doit y avoir une
autre façon de faire les choses en 2019
il participe à une rencontre proposée
par un organisme à but non lucratif qui
enseigne aux agriculteurs les pratiques
régénératrice pour l'ia ni c'est une
révélation
wen c'était comme si la lumière c'était
fait ça avait tellement de sens
qu'ils souhaitent la nature tu paies si
j'arrive à l'imiter je prendrai moindre
risque
j'aurai une meilleure résilience face
aux surprises que nous réservent mère
nature
la seule académie est l'un des
partenaires terrain du géant alimentaire
general mills la multinationale s'est
fixé un objectif voir s'implanter
l'agriculture régénératrice sur plus de
400 mille hectares d'ici 2030 dans le
monde elle cherche donc des fermes pour
un projet pilote le fabricant de
céréales n'achètera pas directement la
récolte des fermes sélectionner les
agriculteurs ne seront pas rémunérés
mais ils seront accompagnés par un
mentor
[Musique]
c'est le rôle que joue blender tasse ce
fermier compte 45 ans d'expérience dont
20 en agriculture régénératrice
le modèle industriel mis de l'avant
depuis 50 ans aux mines la santé des
sols
chaque année elle se détériore et le
modèle est de moins en moins résilient
l'un des piliers de l'agriculture
régénératrice c'est la diversité des
plantes cultivées
dans la nature on ne trouve jamais une
seule variété de plantes mais dans les
champs c'est ce qu'on voit et cette
année en particulier cette approche
montre ses limites
ici c'est une monoculture de canola elle
a été très affectée par la chaleur
pourtant dans les mêmes conditions météo
le même type de sol vous pouvez voir
derrière moi que la culture mixte de
poids et d'orge pousse bien mieux que la
monoculture de canola
et ce malgré la quasi absence d'eau pour
l'ia ni la preuve est faite elle ne
sèmera plus jamais de mono culture de
canola
[Musique]
dans le cadre du projet pilote de trois
ans plusieurs paramètres seront mesurer
et comparer avec des fermes
conventionnelle témoins comme la
présence des insectes et des oiseaux
ou encore la capacité d'infiltration de
l'eau
cela équivaut à des précipitations de 25
mm en 2 minutes l'on a été absorbée dans
le sol
seul conventionnelle moyens mettra dix
minutes pour absorber 25 mm d'eau
s'il pleut très fort les sols dégradés
sont incapables d'absorber l'eau qui va
rapidement gonflé les rivières
on peut faire beaucoup de choses mais on
ne peut pas provoquer la pluie entre
temps on peut préparer le terrain pour
recevoir les précipitations
si les sols en santé peuvent agir comme
une éponge et retenir l'eau ils peuvent
aussi servir d'éponger carbone grâce à
la photosynthèse les plantes captent du
co2 elles relâchent de l'oxygène et
emmagasine le carbone dans leurs tiges
leurs racines et surplus dont elles
n'ont pas besoin se retrouve dans le sol
et vont nourrir les micro organismes en
changeant les pratiques agricoles on
peut donc emmagasiné d'importantes
quantités de carbone ce qui fait dire à
plusieurs qu'une partie de la solution à
la crise climatique se trouveraient sous
nos pieds
la plupart d'entre nous sommes
conscients que nous faisons face à une
crise climatique il en droit logique ou
séquestrés carbone se trouve sous mes
pieds les terres agricoles
bout nous mettons de carbone dans le sol
plus nos systèmes deviennent résilient
et puis à d'activité biologique dans le
sol donc plus de rendement et plus de
profits et à mesure que le marché du
carbone se développent il pourrait
s'avérer de plus en plus payant pour les
agriculteurs de séquestrer le carbone
dans le sol à plusieurs égards
l'agriculture est génératrice force donc
les fermiers à revoir leurs façons de
mesurer le succès financier
nous les fermiers sont payés à la tonne
produite
nous produisons de tonnes plus nous
faisons d'argent à l'hectare
mais il ya un petit piège ici
beaucoup de fermiers achète de grandes
quantités d'engrais chimiques
d'herbicides de fongicides et
d'insecticides pour augmenter les
rendements de façon artificielle
donc si on peut cultiver de manière
régénérative en misant sur l'activité
biologique du sol et en utilisant un
minimum d'intrants chimiques qui
deviendront de moins en moins nécessaire
à mesure que le sol retrouvera la santé
ont réduit grandement les coûts
peut-être qu'on ne récoltera pas autant
de tonnes à l'hectare mais c'est
beaucoup plus rentable est
l'objectif ultime est donc de se passer
de ces produits le plus possible les
produits chimiques les pesticides ne
font que traiter un symptôme et souvent
ils empirent
si des insectes pose un gros problème
dans un méchant oui je vais utiliser un
insecticide parce que je dois sauver ma
culture mais le but c'est de comprendre
pourquoi j'ai ce problème
est ce que je pourrais rendre la plante
plus saine pour empêcher les insectes de
l'attaqué
notre qualité de vie la nourriture qu'on
mange notre propre santé
liés au sol
nous ramène à la terre
et où on n'a fait que si nous voulons
prendre soin du sol pour nous et pour
les générations à venir
le champ c'est moi qui m'en occupe mais
le sol n'est pas moi c'est ce qu'ont au
pur produit et puis c'est ce qu'on va
laisser aux autres pour produire aussi
même les artisans de la grande
entreprise
ils se rendent compte que nos sols se
dégrade et que ça pose des problèmes
pour leur propre profit
je crois que ça relève en partie du
marketing être versé à la mode
aujourd'hui c'est un élément positif que
des grandes entreprises pensent à la
régénération des sols c'est un bon pas
en avant mais il faudra pas s'arrêter là
ce présent dans la mode aller dans
l'espace mèche où il investit des
milliards dans ciel on devrait investir
d'argent dans le sol pour comprendre la
microbiologie comprendre le
fonctionnement de ce jeune et moins
jeunes tous on devrait s'intéresser à ce
c'est ce que c'est l'avenir de la
planète
[Musique]
et pour ceux qui se demandent ce qui est
advenu debrecen et de leurs citrouilles
géantes
et bien c'est qu'elle s'y qui avait
raison en octobre les bryson ont
fracassé le record de la plus grosse
citrouille au canada en franchissant
pour la première fois la barre des 2000
livres c'est plus de 900 kg tout ça sans
avoir recours aux engrais chimiques